للشعب الفلسطيني الحق في
وطنه، بعد أن عانى
أجيالاً من السلب والقمع والاحتلال،
وانتهاكات حقوق الإنسان التي يجب أن تهز الإنسانية
الليلة جحيماً، تمطر على غزة، غزة،
مقبرة الأطفال، حياة طفل
تُزهق كل 10 دقائق، وتدعي إسرائيل أنها
تتصرف من تلقاء نفسها.  دفاعاً عن
القصف الشامل للمدنيين،
العقاب الجماعي، ذبح الأطفال
بالآلاف، ليس
دفاعاً، هذه ليست
ردوداً مبررة على الهجوم المروع الذي شنته
حماس في السابع من أكتوبر/تشرين الأول، يرى العالم
الأفعال الإسرائيلية على حقيقتها، إنها
جرائم حرب وحشية وجبانة، هذه لحظة حساب لـ
قادة العالم للاتحاد الأوروبي
اختبار للالتزام بحقوق الإنسان
والديمقراطية والسلام، ونسأل أين حماية
القانون الدولي لكل طفل
يُقتل في غزة ولكل غاز وأم
تحمل جسد طفلها الميت البارد،
لا يمكن السماح لإسرائيل بارتكاب
الفظائع  تقول الحكومة، مع الإفلات من العقاب،
إن تصرفات إسرائيل لا يمكن أن تكون
دون
عواقب، وأنا
أوافق على ذلك، ولهذا السبب يجب على الحكومة الأيرلندية أن
تأخذ زمام المبادرة وتحيل إسرائيل إلى
المحكمة الجنائية الدولية
وترسل السفير الإسرائيلي إلى
وطنه
[تصفيق]
عندما تعطي المفوضية الأوروبية العربة
البيضاء لإسرائيل  إلى مذبحة
الفلسطينيين نقول لا أبدًا، لا تتحدثون
باسمنا، يجب على إسرائيل أن توقف مذبحتها في
غزة، يجب على حماس إطلاق سراح جميع الرهائن، لذلك
الليلة من أيرلندا نقول بصوت عالٍ أوقفوا إطلاق
النار
[تصفيق]
الآن